All right, in this next example software under test is some sort of a web service,
and what I'm going to do is I'm just going to go ahead and roll this out
onto one of the machines in our cluster, but I'm not going to expose this to most of our users.
What I'm going to do is expose this machine
to some small fraction of our users who have been selected, for example,
based on their willingness and desire to use new features.
The question is what kind of testing is this most like?
Is this integration testing?
Is it differential testing? Is it random testing?
Or is this system/validation testing?
Okay, so please take a second to go ahead and
mark what you believe is the kind of testing that's the best match
for what it is that we're doing here.